hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I apologize for
being a few minutes late I got a phone
call right before the stream started I
should have never even answered it but
it was from a car rental place and I'd
run in a car last week to drive down to
revolution conf and there were some
issues with the car rental in terms of
like there was a misunderstanding and I
ended up getting charged more than I
should have gotten charged so I did
really when I answer it and clear that
up so anyway good news for me is that
everything is gonna be cleared up and I
I definitely apologize for for the
lateness of the stream start alright so
I just want to take let me take a minute
here I'm streaming from home so I want
to make sure the streams okay so let me
know if anything's weird with the stream
if there's a delay right now it says the
health is good but I have more things
running on my computer that I normally
do when I try to stream so so far
everything's running good just let me
know I'm not gonna play Spotify on my
computer I'm gonna hook it up on my
phone so I'm gonna set this up right now
[Music]
play this okay yeah and then this is
somewhat humorous I I went to start the
stream because I was in a hurry because
I was late and then I looked in OBS and
I can see myself and realize that I did
not have a shirt on so then I had to
grab a shirt really quick before I could
start so I had already started the
stream done the preview on YouTube and
you have to hit one more button for it
to go live so I
most had hit the the third button not
you can really see much more than this
up but still I I didn't want to
scandalize anybody uh-huh all right I'm
gonna check the live chat real quick
before we get started and I'm gonna
start out by explaining what we're doing
and why we're doing it and then we'll
get right into it just a disclaimer I've
never done this before so this is gonna
be one of those streams where we learn
together and I'm expecting for it not to
work right away so we'll just we'll see
how it goes I see if you were saying hi
[Music]
so vendor hi Edward says who else is
excited I'm definitely excited I hope
some of you were excited too treasurer
says hi hey how's the corn Mildred says
it's looking good I assume you mean the
stream is looking good and not
necessarily me but if you did mean me
thank you either way Thanks
Jeff's I thought you were laying on the
floor for a second there yeah actually
it does kind of look like I'm laying
down it's I'm actually in a recliner and
then behind me I just put up tablecloths
I hung them from the ceiling so it kind
of encloses me a bit and that way if my
kids run through here then it's not
distracting and you never know there's a
bathroom like in the corner there so
sometimes the little ones will be so
excited that they went on the party
they'll run through here without any
pants on or anything so just wanted to
make sure we keep this PG here and
family-friendly let's see I'll just read
a few more hellos before we get started
Carlos says hasn't been able to watch
previous episodes cuz I didn't get home
until now good to see you live it's good
to have you here live Carlos let's see
Harshit says hasn't worked with much
width now lately well that's where
actually
getting ready to work with now so we're
not gonna get there today but we're
gonna do the prep work for our WordPress
installation to get to that point let's
see kcb says No Pants Wednesday I do
have pants on well I have shorts on so
let's all right cool
all right let's get started first thing
I'm gonna do is just give you quick
explanation on what we're doing and I'm
gonna paste a link in here for you to
follow along with some of the
documentation as well let me get that
link right now I had it up on my other
computer okay I got the link now let me
paste this for you I'm a paces here in
the live chat if it doesn't work when
you click it just try copying and
pasting it that usually works and this
video is kind of dark I'm gonna brighten
my screen it's amazing the difference
you get in the video if you I just
brighten my laptop screen okay so I'm
gonna move this over on my other screen
and I'm gonna share my screen with you
all so we can all check it out together
okay so this is what we're looking at
and this is the link that I copied in I
what I'd like to do is set up WordPress
in a way that I can track it with git
and that I can also deploy it using now
so if you've used WordPress before and
if you know anything about now you know
that that's it's not gonna work right
off the bat we definitely have to change
some things so this is an in
anticipation of putting in motion the
plan that we talked about on Monday so
that we're gonna separate out that my
sequel database and all the files all
the media files from WordPress and then
all we'll have left are you know the PHP
files the plugins things like that
that's what's gonna end up being hosted
with now so that's what we're gonna work
on today we're gonna take the actual
WordPress files that we've been using
and we're gonna try to get them into
this format and put them up on github so
let's dig into this a little bit and
just see what's going on so that we can
all get on idea of what we need to do so
you can see we're running you know we
have our WP config file which I'm sure
we'll have to modify but that's standard
[Music]
we have this docker file so we check
darker this will really give us an idea
of like what's going and what's gonna go
on inside the stock or container you see
we're doing this curl right if you're
not familiar with these commands curl is
like going out and like downloading
stuff and in this case it's downloading
these zip files so you know we're
getting latest versions of WordPress
we're getting some plugins for secure
database connection we're getting a
SendGrid plugin wordpress dusts and
emails for just some of its
administrative tasks so we're gonna run
that through SendGrid
and we should be able to just use the
free plate on send great because there's
it there's not gonna be very many emails
and we already have SendGrid account set
up so we won't have to set anything new
up for that alright it's using hmm sorry
so you can see when we run docker it's
it is going through all the steps to run
WordPress to install and run WordPress
with nginx so this is really cool we
haven't use docker on the show so I mean
I'm kind of excited about this and so
that's that's what's gonna be going on
inside the container okay and you see if
there's anything else that we need to
you know we ought to check out this
config file makes me check out this run
file - okay and the config I'm assuming
this is not gonna be a little different
than a normal WP config all right see we
are gonna have to put in some info
okay I mean it actually looks pretty
much somewhat normal okay
and I forget stuff over doors ever I'm
sorry about that let's started now and
I'm just gonna keep it on my other
screen I already have it there it'll
play a sound in my headphones whenever X
no it won't play us on because I have my
headphones plugged in my phone but oh uh
it should give me a notification let's
see Harshit says you need environment
variables yes yes thank you yeah so what
we're not going to have on our github
repo is our environment variables right
because obviously we don't want the
world to know all that stuff so I will
set that if we get to that point where
we get far enough that we need to set
these things up then I will definitely
do that on my other screen and we'll
have to keep them you know elsewhere
okay all right how she's talking about
the 'flag on now let's see what they
have set up for now there we go
so hard [ __ ] I don't I don't know if you
were looking at this or not on your
machine but this is the now JSON so at
least we know what we need
all right so what we want to do I guess
first did I clone this already I can't
remember if I fork this yet or not so
let me double check and see if I did
forked it yet and then we can get
started let's see I I as I believe I'm
pronouncing that right I'm not sure
though I as I see your questions after
this Pomodoro session I'll come through
and answer a bunch of the question so
you can just hold on for about 20
minutes or so then I'll answer the
questions all right so let's check out
my profile
and
if I did clone it I think I would have
cloned it to this organization this FPS
mark on that's alright I keep saying
clone I mean fork so there we go I did
it's here okay so I'm gonna run from off
of this now this repository that I
forked you can see for this main
repository it's it's not like it's been
updated any time soon so I don't really
need to worry about updating my fork so
we can get rid of that and let's let's
clone this then and this it may take a
few minutes since I'm trying to run OBS
at the same time but that's okay because
that would give me a little bit of time
to check out the live chat and I have
this really small so I'm gonna make
these a bit bigger before I do anything
else
it looks really huge on my screen let me
know if it's good for you all so I'm
gonna do oops I want to get out you know
what I don't want to do this in in here
let's let's pull up a command line so
let's go into here for now
okay so I'm in my projects folder if
you're doing things with the command
line pulling on repos I always find it
helpful to create a projects folder or
so I know where everything is at just
keep things clean for me so I'm going to
do a git clone and I'm bringing down
that repo Wow super fast okay and we can
CD into this
it's just WordPress and we can see hey
here's all our files now I'm gonna open
this with Visual Studio code I know I
could have opened up a window in code
first but I've just got into the habit
of doing it this way and I always have
my item open anyway so I'm not on
absentia when it's faster but it's
easier for me since it's a habit now
remind me later I've been asking him to
remind me later for that survey for
months maybe one day I'll actually do it
I mean I do want to help
I just am always in the middle of
something okay so you can see now we
have all those files right everything
that we we ought to have so what we can
try to do now is set this up and try to
get something running locally on the
machine so let me I'd say you know what
I think I may have to set up if this end
good stuff is not optional which it
doesn't look like it is how about it
I'm gonna try to run it without setting
up something on SendGrid
but if you know what SendGrid is it's
like an email server so we've done
things with SendGrid before it won't be
too much of an issue but I think we can
see
save some time and try to do it without
SendGrid we'll see if we get an error
then we'll set it up but you know it's
worth saving like 10 or 15 minutes to
try to do it without SendGrid first
since this is you know kind of a trial
run this is the first time we're trying
this yeah I'm trying to scan the the
chat as well just to see or should I see
I see your comments let's do that now
then let's make that dot end file no it
didn't
I didn't hit the dot hard enough there
we go dot okay so our dot end file env
is where we're going to add in all the
stuff that we saw here right the host
user name all that so let me open this
side by side so I get them all and I
just want to grab these just so that we
have them and take let me take out all
these quotation marks we don't need them
okay and I don't believe we don't need
the commas either know what I just did
there we go all right I don't think we
need anything I'm just gonna need what
like equals
maybe equals for all that so at this
point I am going to pull this off to
another screen let me get let me see if
I can open this in another
I guess it's not gonna let me do that I
just see axle s what's with that end
this for I need all these values to get
this up and running so I need to put
them in an end file and then now is
gonna grab them and use them so that's
what I need I should thanks he just
reminded me to remove the spaces as well
I assumed you meant the stuff over here
so thank you for that and let me make a
new window and pull it over to my other
screen and now I should be able to drag
this over it's my new window and close
it here all right cool so let me just
open up this just to have something else
in here we're gonna close that and I
will do my best to never show that end
file again let's see Harshit says is the
database set up or will you use the same
test database for now I'm going to use
the same test database so I don't have
the things we talked about in terms of
on Monday in terms of file storage and
database I don't have setup yet because
it occurred to me that the school that I
work for uses Microsoft Office 365
so I thought it might be a good idea to
look into like hey could we use Azure
for free or for a big discount so the IT
department is looking into that right
now I hope I get an answer back soon if
it turns out that we get a really good
deal then I may go with Azure for our
database management and
file storage if not I think I'll
probably end up going with Google
because from from what I've seen so far
I think Google will end up being a bit
cheaper so that's the plan right now if
I don't hear anything back by the end of
the week I'm I think I'm just gonna go
with Google stuff because I can't really
wait all right let's see I'm gonna grab
all right I'm gonna look away from the
live chat for a while because I need the
screen space to look up some info about
my WordPress installation okay so let me
see I may have to
trying to think how I can get this info
quickly
maybe I'll just SSH into the droplet and
bring up the current WP config I just
need to get the IP for the droplet
all right so I'd rather not show you all
my my stuff for this process so I'm
gonna just describe it as best I can so
right now all I'm doing is just logging
into digitalocean
it's asking me for my two-factor
authentication so I just need to get it
on my phone here and get that I use
authy for my authentication I have a lot
of stuff in here it takes me a little
while to find it I definitely recommend
using two-factor authentication whenever
it is available definitely better than
just using a password okay so let me go
in here I'm in digitalocean I am I'm on
several digitalocean teams so I'm
switching to the team that we have for
for this University
we have quite a few droplets in here
Anna
I don't remember what the name of this
chocolate is
okay I think it's this one let me double
check before I started trying to get
into this job
let's try I'm gonna try to do some stuff
here just to show you let's do a new tab
and let's see I think that's it you know
it's denied alright hold on a second let
me bring this to my other screen
okay
all right so evidently I don't think I
set this one up but evidently I am NOT
set up as a user oh you know what this
was we did the like easy one-click setup
for this and so I personally don't have
an account like I usually set up but the
root account is still active now it's
not you can't pat get a password it's
setup through SSH keys which is okay but
usually we don't use the root account
for time I'm not gonna set up my own
account right now let's just do this
with root I have to remember how to get
to this over you to it I can't remember
how to get to where we want to go
okay if anybody remembers how to
navigate file structure for Apache to
get to where WordPress is let me know
I cannot remember I'm just not in this
file structure often enough all right
let's check out what we have
Jacob says www yeah that's what I'm
looking for the WWE but I just can't
there that's it yeah I couldn't remember
what the the top one was or far how do
you pronounce that there or far I don't
know there we go but Thank You Jacob all
right so we get there we go there's my
wp-config should be there yeah all right
I'm gonna pull this off my screen for a
second so I don't reveal all my secrets
to the world and then that's what I'm
gonna use to put stuff in that end file
so all I'm just gonna run this with nano
so I can't show you on the screen but
I'm just gonna say I'm running the
command nano which is a built-in text
editor and it's probably the easiest one
to use and that's really all I need
right now and I'm gonna do nano and open
the WP config dot PHP file wonderful so
now I'm going to scroll down a bit to
get the values that I need
okay now don't show anyone your
wp-config file so if you're ever going
through this you definitely don't don't
want to show people
okay so I have all the database info in
there right now so we'll see if this
works hopefully it does and now that I
have that in there let's go back here
and terminal all right so we have our
terminal running down here at the bottom
which is very nice built-in feature here
and I guess let's y'all run this
all right so this didn't come with a
readme file for what to run this what's
what's the command to run this docker
file well I wonder if I could just run
now let's just do that let's right now
please enter values to the following
environment variables oh no I wants me
to enter values for them why can't it
just pull it from the start and file
okay let me
all right I'm gonna stop that here and
then what happened my terminal oh I put
it over here all right let me run this
in my terminal
I could put in this stuff
okay we need the SendGrid api key so it
wouldn't let me proceed without the API
key all right let's set that up and I
can show this on the screen all the way
up until I actually get the API key so
let's go into SendGrid
I didn't really think I'd have to get a
cent good for this dream well you know
what I bet my time yeah my time is
almost up so in about a minute I'm gonna
stop and answer some questions if you
have any questions put them in the live
chat now I used to log into SendGrid
all the time and I've not logged in for
quite a while
all right
API key okay cool so what I'm gonna do
is create another API key
oops I'm gonna do that after our break
so I'm gonna take a short 5-minute break
and I'm gonna go to the chat and answer
some questions I'm gonna scroll of's to
the top and just go down in
chronological order and try to answer as
much as I can then when I come back then
we're gonna set up API keys so that we
can hopefully get this word press
running on now
I see a lot more of you were saying
hello I'm not gonna go through everybody
but just hey everyone
Phoenix says I just wanted to inform you
that I might be off the streams for a
few days I have my masters exams due
next month hey no problem good luck with
your your exams I hope you do well and
after y'all finish come back on and let
us know how you did
I don't know if you can hear my stomach
growling if you can I apologize I need
to eat
okay so I as had that question a while
back I noticed that how can I learn
coding I'm a beginner
looks like our Nora
Arnaldo says go to free code camp yeah
definitely free code camps a great way
to start I mean it does depend on
exactly what you want but if you're not
sure what you want to do I definitely
recommend going to free code camp org
and just starting out you know go
through some of their stuff definitely
at least get to the point where you're
starting to learn JavaScript you know
get through the HTML and CSS stuff you
know try to stick with it through you
know through that to the JavaScript
algorithms and things and maybe try
making some of the projects nice to give
you a good idea of how you like coding
and you know I think it's a good way to
start out there's a lot of other places
you could start out with but III think
that's a pretty solid foundation
Schoop um says what about react projects
yeah we're still working on a react
project this is just the the piece of
the project where we're restoring the
data and managing the data so we're
gonna set this up and then we'll be
going back to the react stuff soon I was
actually working on that the react stuff
all day trying to get more more route
set up and pulling the data correctly
Nikki says the optional chaining
proposal announced in stage one possibly
coming in JavaScript will be awesome for
the router file on the project that's
cool our routers getting huge
and anything to help out with that would
be great
is you're a genius Jesse thank you I
appreciate that I'm not exactly sure I'm
a genius but if you say so
I'm not gonna argue
Oh an ich es would hotkey I removed the
indentation with I just highlighted
everything and I pressed shift tab so
just backwards tab everything I've got a
question where can I learn WordPress
theme construction
I believe the WordPress documentation
actually has a step-by-step process of
learning theme construction so I would
check that out
that's probably gonna be where you'll
have the most up-to-date and official
instructions on how to do it so to just
check out the WordPress Doc's on that I
haven't attempted to construct the
WordPress theme for years so I'm not I I
know where I go if I wanted to to do it
and that's the official documentation
but I'm I'm just not in practice to be
able to just go in and start doing it
myself
hiki says there's a folder called magic
isn't really a folder called magic in
there
I did not see that
I don't know if I see it again then
maybe I'll try
alright my timer is out so if I didn't
get to your question right now I will
get to it after the next break so I'm
gonna start up this next moment or a
session
[Music]
let's get excluding billing yeah that's
fine okay key name hopefully this
doesn't exposed my API key right away I
did we cannot show to you again dang it
alright let's try this again
off screen
alright so I'm gonna save this stuff in
my last pass
okay
all right now let me see if I can I can
get this running
all right so I'm just making sure I copy
all these keys properly
that's weird it did not work
we've scrolling through the chat quickly
to see if anyone noticed anything I was
doing wrong
oh there I don't see anything
but
all right I'm gonna try this one more
time just in case I you know pasted
something in here wrong and if that
doesn't work then we'll maybe try to
look up and get some help on this
okay got further than I did last time
all right it's going it's doing a lot of
stuff in the terminal no errors so far
yes we'll just see what's gonna happen
all right it's downloading and unzipping
different things WordPress files I can
see okay cool
yeah let me I'll put my terminal back
over here if I accidentally show some
type of info that I shouldn't then I
guess I can always just change it
alright so while that's going I'll just
I'll check in to see some of what's
going on in the chat
Oh Andrew landed his first deaf job
congratulations that's awesome whoa all
right that's cool so maybe that works
name password information you pick to go
to good database hmm okay well it was
cool that we got it to run evidently I
messed up something with the database
let's make sure I hope I didn't actually
mess up the database itself so I'm gonna
double-check here
and then says get versus SVN I've never
used that's the end so I'm gonna go with
get but I'm not I can't really make a
good comparison Jacob asked if SendGrid
is free yes so they have a free tier
that works for a lot of a lot of things
so definitely check out the free tier
and that may be all you need for you
whatever project you're working on
let me try to get in somewhere that will
pull from the database I know this will
work I've been working on this page for
a while okay cool so the database is not
broken it's just the way I tried to
bring it into that project that's that's
broken
alright I'm gonna check out much time
i-i've and then we'll see what we can do
here ok
all right what if we check this out
let's check this out so we're gonna
check out Google Cloud my sequel
let's just do this we'll just try to go
through quickly and do this alright so
I'm gonna pull these instructions over
on my other screen
leaky just said thought he was going to
Google Google for a second
almost aged like 50 years in an instant
all right so let's go to let's create a
project and let's call this a test test
my sequel that looks good location
organization can I just leave it with
none yeah all right cool
need to enable billing this is my own
account so I'm just gonna do this on my
own account just to get it working
should be billing area
if
there we go okay I still have this link
to my billing account I don't know I'm
not getting charged for anything so I
guess it's okay anyway
alright so billing is linked up now lets
enable API API so this is the Google
cloud platform admin panel let me make
it a bit bigger sorry about that I just
realized though it's probably really
small oops I thought I clicked on API me
to enable an API there we go so it's
enable
and I guess I'm looking for the actually
researchers Google cloud sequel API
and they will
all right cool let's make sure let me
pull this over make sure I enable this
for specific projects
I was thinking it I accidentally enabled
it for the wrong projects let me disable
that for this project yeah the safe
let me get on the right project here now
a double check to make sure it is
enabled all right it is enabled also
very possible let's go to our cloud
sequel instances page
you know what I'm gonna paste the
QuickStart into the live chat as well
and then that way y'all can follow along
if you'd like I definitely want to go
with my sequel
sure let's choose second generation look
better choice is permanent for instance
ID
sq instance root password
whoops generate and not show me no I
want everybody to know let me I'm gonna
generate a different password with
LastPass
there we go and ace this
occasion central yeah that's fun let's
check out these options probably just
leave it all by default we're gonna
create this instance
all right cool so that is doing its
thing and the next step is we're gonna
get access to a console then we'll be
able to create the database and actually
let's see if we can migrate our database
I'm just gonna while this does its thing
I'm gonna search to see if there's a
really easy way to my grades and it
looks like there is some documentation
on how to my grade patient database
so I'm gonna have to dump the database
okay
all right Nikki says the stream is
cutting out no maybe maybe I'm trying to
do too much it's possible I have too
much stuff running oh and my timer is up
all right so we got a way for this to be
finished anyway so now I guess it's a
good time for a break so let me go back
to the chat let's see what what kind of
questions you have
andrew says do companies give you
computers to develop on yeah my my
company does the laptop I'm using right
now is my own but in my office at work I
have an iMac so I think it's pretty
common for a company to supply you with
a computer
nan says Jessie any words on tensorflow
Jas I have not worked with tensorflow
Jas it's it's I would love to work with
tensorflow and all the stuff like that I
just haven't had a time yet so I have
some ideas on how I could use it but I I
really can't give any comment on it yet
because I I haven't had time to use it
if anybody else has used it I'd love to
hear your opinion on it world's ass
would ascend reduce for its it's
unlikely mail client so you can if you
need your app to send emails then
instead of like writing the code to send
email to yourself you can just use send
grid's API send the data to send grid
and then it will handle all the email
stuff for you so we've used it on some
previous projects and it's it's pretty
pretty easy to use a it works cool new
world says how good should I be at
vanilla JavaScript before learning a
framework like view it works it's like
Dom manipulation I mean realistically I
I have not used view but I think it's
somewhat similar to react and you don't
do a lot of direct Dom manipulation and
react so if you is like that don't worry
so much about Dom manipulation and if
you wanna see the I you know if you know
just the very basics of JavaScript you
can jump into a framework or library and
that should be fine you know just make
sure you keep learning JavaScript while
you're doing it I sometimes people talk
about like mastering job vanilla
JavaScript before they move on but I'm
I don't I think
that's if you had all the time in the
world and all the money in the world and
you didn't have to worry about actually
producing work for clients therefore
your you know your employer then yeah
maybe you could do it like that but
realistically like frameworks and
libraries are there so that you don't
have to do all the underlying stuff you
can just make awesome things and have
that layer of abstraction that it makes
it easier for you to do not only that
but you know if you rely on a framework
or a library to do a lot of things for
you and a lot of other people use that
then it's well tested the bugs are all
out if you try to build everything from
scratch yourself with vanilla JavaScript
odds are there's gonna be a lot of cases
where it doesn't work and you were not
even gonna know about it at first and
you may never know about it you know it
may affect some users and you never even
hear from them so I I think as soon as
you know enough to start to understand
the basics of a framework it's fine to
just jump into that framework you will
continue to learn JavaScript as you use
that framework as long as the framework
isn't like such an abstraction that you
don't use any JavaScript like react
isn't like that I don't think you is
like that you continue to use a lot of
basic JavaScript stuff as you do that
you know as you use your your library
I as is not a fan of the free code camp
lesson so it's asking for something else
I says I am 17 I read in class time tell
me yeah if you if you're not a fan of
the free code camp stuff I mean maybe if
you prefer like just reading try out the
you don't know J S series that's
available for free online also eloquent
JavaScript is available for free
Udacity has some nice intro courses that
are also free and it's a mix of video
and exercises and projects so a little
bit different from free code camp you
know I would try those out see how you
like those
okay
all right the timer went up again so
let's let's just try one more time to
get this running now with our new
database and so what we need to do then
is pull the stuff from our current
database and then import it into our our
database
let me
if I give up my terminal where did it go
oh it's over here all right if we're
still here let's try this and her
password let me pull this off to the
side while Ana's password it may not
even show up in the terminal but rather
be safe about this
copy that password and paste it
[Music]
all right awesome so let me go back over
here and let's see
[Music]
cool we have this backup file now just
back up dot SQL alright so we have a
backup of our database and we need to
import the database
okay let me go in now and I'm gonna log
in to that my sequel database not
letting we're you know letting me copy
and paste
no there we go so let's grab that and
let's get in here
this is H assuming I'm rude
what's it doing come on
yeah
I'm gonna skip this step let's get the
Sun yep I did I forgot a set
Claude show alright it's fine the cloud
shell icon there we go okay so this is
gonna be you know just like a terminal
there we go
all right so let's try to get in here
and
I see like a g-cloud cool connects and
connection name maybe I need to use that
I'm not exactly sure what name I need to
use for this so let's try this user
equals root error okay so that's
obviously not the right name so let's
try a different name
maybe we can try the IP address you know
let's see test my sequel instance let's
try that yeah maybe now I didn't want it
to do it again alright let me go over
here while that's going again just to
check the chat
oh yeah there's definitely someone is
asking about if this could be posted
later it will definitely yeah don't
worry about if it's 3 a.m. you know by
all means go to sleep this will be
available the recording will be
available online so here on the freako
Camp YouTube channel so yeah definitely
definitely do that oh that was cool it
actually filled out what I needed
waitlisting your IP for incoming
connection for five minutes
excellent
and your root password okay yes all
right so I'm in and I did that
I'm fall along with some instructions
here so that's why it sounds like I'm
talk to myself
okay cool
so let's do a few things here to set
this up so that we can migrate this so
we're gonna go we're gonna create this
database we're gonna call it WordPress
and we're gonna end that with a
semicolon
okay and then we're going to we're at
all privileges on WordPress to admin
we can you can use any username you want
for that we're just gonna do Evan Bayh
and alright house where it isn't the
best password but since this is just a
test and I'm gonna shut this down right
after then this is okay alright
wonderful now we're going to disconnect
hopefully let's make sure I did that
right
I forgot that I have an air dang it yeah
writing sequel commands in terminal is
always rough especially because of the
semicolons at the end so that was my
problem now I'm gonna exit okay you can
tell I'm not used to this sequel
terminal commands I've done it before
but not often okay now for this next
part here's we're gonna do when I run my
sequel you admin P and then we're gonna
put the IP address of the database
whoops so I think I skipped a step all
right let me go back here and authorize
actually I don't think I need this
anymore let me close this out for now
you can always come back in if I need to
I need to authorize this other database
so authorize network we need to add a
network and we need to put the IP
address of our our test or our WordPress
database so the one we want to bring the
data in from all right wonderful now in
that where's my table
there we go so now back here let's make
sure we're still in here great now we're
gonna do my sequel you admin pH we need
the IP address of our my sequel instance
let's grab that and put that in here so
what we're gonna do is is pull that data
that we made that backup that back up
sequel here we're gonna push that over
into our our new Google Cloud sequel
database let's try that IP address and
we're gonna send that over to WordPress
right because that's the name of the
database that we just created that's
pretty much empty
wrong way and we're gonna grab that back
up the sequel file and we should need a
password and the password for that user
was password so I think that should work
not sure how long this is going to take
so I'll read some from the oh wait a
second Jeff says did you save that
change no what did I not say did I not
save with the authorization I hope I
didn't save shoot is that which was yeah
save it
I'll probably get rejected I might have
to just run that command again shoot
count him an important step huh did it
work done save there we go good catch on
that one I totally didn't even see it so
I'll probably just as soon as it's safe
I'll just cancel that command and then
rerun it because this is gonna allow
permission for stuff to come from this
IP address and make changes here all
right so let's stop that ctrl C and run
this again hopefully we'll get something
this time and let's see
try to see the logs see what's happening
alright so I'm not sure if anything
happen or not but let's check it out
interesting
all right
I just want to try to verify that this
did something
I mean we definitely had a spike in
storage right about the time when I ran
that command so that's probably a good
sign
Jeff says run the my sequel a
command-line interface on the target see
if you got anything there
oh yeah that's definitely a great idea
see I'm just gonna do that cuz it'll
just automatically put in the command
for me that I need
make sure you do is whoops let me copy
this password
it's
and if it saved any of my previous
dreams there
all right what sequel command is just
gonna let me see what's in this
WordPress database really quick if
anyone knows please put it in the live
chat otherwise I'm just gonna look it up
all Jeff and use WordPress okay
show tables thank you yes all right
cool really cool okay so now let me
change
all right let me run grab this and I'm
gonna try running now again and I'm
gonna put in the new info for the new
database both of you who helped me out I
very much appreciate the help that
definitely saved me minutes of looking
up this stuff
all right cool so I can't remember if it
made me I can't remember if it made me
put in the all the password stuff and it
actually displayed it so I'm gonna do
this off screen all I'm doing off screen
is it's just asking me for the database
host name password and stuff like that
I'm just copying pasting value so yeah
and it is actually showing the values
sir
all right it's it's running it's
building I'll throw this back over here
now y'all can see some of this stuff
[Music]
yeah so I'm gonna go back to live chat
answer some questions while this does
its thing basically if I'm gonna run
this once if it works wonderful if it
doesn't work then I'll have to try again
later because we've been streaming for a
long time I need to eat believe it or
not streaming actually takes a lot out
of you wow that was so fast let's try it
out
no error it's me unit password and your
wp-config.php file it's incorrect or we
can't contact the database
yeah it should be these should all be
pulling in the right stuff
all right something's still happening
I'm not sure I thought I had the right
stuff
oh you know what I may have made just a
very simple error I'm gonna go I'm gonna
run this again since it went so quickly
and I'm gonna try again
and if this doesn't work then I'm really
done this time
okay bring this over imagine this
probably a lot in the live chat that I
need to catch up on before we end let me
try to find where I left off
alright let's show this out
eret again all right so what I'll
probably need to do at this point is see
if anybody else has try to do this and
has had similar problems double check
and make sure all my my passwords and
stuff or huh so I make sure they're all
correct and let's try to figure it out
by it
at least for me I learned some good
stuff today that I'm happy I did so I
learned how to go through the process on
Google cloud to set up this sequel
database which was actually really easy
I learned how to copy everything over
which was also pretty easy so I think it
was definitely worthwhile we set up a
service insane grid yeah so I don't know
pretty cool I'll definitely have to do
the the setup of the server again you
know in the Google cloud if that's what
I ended up going with because obviously
I'm not gonna personally pay for this
since it's for my employer but yeah a
little disappointed we didn't get it
working completely but we ended up
actually setting up more than I expected
because I didn't think we'd have to do
this whole database thing so anyway I
hope you all learned something as well
and I'm gonna get through these last few
questions here and then I'm gonna call
it a day for this the stream
yeah Nietzsche says Google recursion do
it do it now just for fun all right
let's Google recursion I love it it says
do you mean recursion so I mean if you
get it you get it otherwise lookup
recursion all right so like there's it's
a the live chats actually a lot of y'all
talking to each other and helping each
other out which is awesome I love when
that happens so thank you good new yeah
were you doing baby but my one-year-old
daughter wants to come see me so she's
upset I'm still working
kevin says what continuous integration
tools do you use in your company shoot
what did we just start using Travis we
just started using Travis what do you
all think about Travis or other other
tools like that what do you use with
your opinions on them I'm pretty new
into that kind of thing so any advice
you have is very welcome
Richard Coad says hey Jesse just signed
on have you used local bye flywheel it's
so good I have not used it yet I will
have to check it out
I haven't even really heard about it how
John Hanson's here says hey oh I missed
it all I'll watch it later as Jesse says
he sounds more intelligent at 1.25 speed
I really do if you haven't tried
watching the recording of the video at a
faster speed try it because when I
normally do the stream I take pauses and
try to figure out what I'm doing and
what I'm gonna say next
but when you speed it up I don't so I
type really fast and I talk fast so I
sound like I always know what I'm doing
it's better if I have to watch my own
videos i watch it like that it makes me
feel better about myself
Jeff says try the migrate DB plug-in
okay I'll yeah I'll have to try that
thank you alright Richard Coad says it's
an environment for WordPress downloads
and installs WordPress for you creates
database and links fires up a local
server amazing oh cool that does sound
amazing thank you for for sharing that
all right I'm at the bottom of the live
chat I'm super hungry and so I'm gonna
end this now
I should be able to stream tomorrow I'll
be in the office so be a little bit
better quality be able to stream in full
HD yeah I think that's about it thank
you all so much for sticking with me for
so long and through so many issues I did
warn you at the beginning stuff was not
gonna work but I still do appreciate you
all with all your help and hopefully
I'll get this working and can show you
something you know it's actually working
tomorrow
but until then have a great day